each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
that's gas starter was the next session
our first speak of this session it's
bill how from University of Washington
so my claim is that the microphone is on
does it sound like it is okay so talking
about a project that i did with a
research programmer named erik Cole we
also have a UI design development team
there on the left and some students and
faculty and computer science on some of
the research projects that are related
to this but mostly I'm just can we talk
about the basic system that is not
necessarily computer science research
this work is funded by a Gordon Betty
Moore Foundation and Microsoft Research
and I work at the other you science
institute we have a logo here here's the
URL if you type in V Science Institute
with or without the hyphen and being
we're the first link and you can do the
same thing in Google ok so the context
here is that there's a lot of talk about
big science and large data and science
but there's the long tail of science
right there's this article in 2004 from
wire they tried to describe the
compliment of big science but they
didn't want to say small science because
that's sort of disparaging so they sort
of coined this term the long tail which
is to do used to describe the large
number of small labs individual
researchers that collectively are
producing the bulk of scientific output
but don't necessarily have the IT
infrastructure to cope with the growing
data sizes right so megabytes three
years ago are becoming gigabytes because
you have sort of hundreds of
spreadsheets instead of one and each one
has three was nine or two more rows in
it and so on and so that's sort of the
context of the area that we're doing
some of this work okay and so yeah the
long tail is getting fatter over time
all right so the problem is this we pose
this question to various labs that we
work with how much time do you spend
quote handling data as opposed to quote
doing science and we didn't define these
terms that we didn't ask them to define
these terms we just sort of asked them
what they thought about this and the
only real distinguishing point we're
trying to make is that you know that
handling data that does not help you do
your science as opposed to him
that's actually appropriate now what's
the overhead what's the wasted time
spans so what do you think the most
common answer was any guesses alright so
the I knew this is a small sample sizes
not a rigorous study we want to put a
survey into this but the answer we
getting back was 90% this is a
staggering number right this is taxpayer
money that goes to NSF to come back to
go to a postdoc and a graduate student
that's been ninety percent of their time
in their own words handling data as
opposed to doing science right now the
people that didn't say ninety percent of
people that said must something was a
little bit more reasonable like thirty
percent or forty percent what do you
think all those people had in common
prsa have people working for them right
so even those p is who I would have
thought spend zero percent of their time
handling data but I'd still say they
spend thirty percent meanwhile they're
also asking questions of their posts
talking and graduate students to go
fetch them answers to data and bring it
back okay so there's an enormous amount
of overhead here in messing with data so
what leaving an example of the kind of
scenario in which this problem manifests
so environmental metagenomics if you're
not familiar the term metagenomics
refers to study of entire populations as
opposed to individual organisms and so
what you might you might do something
like this you take samples from the
environment under various conditions and
different salinities and different
temperatures across the diurnal cycle
across tidal cycles at different depths
and so on and you try to characterize in
terms of two questions who's there and
what are they doing right so what what
organisms are present in the sample and
what genes are being expressed right so
the DNA and the RNA and so you'll take
these samples and you'll sequence them
and then you'll do quite a bit of
processing on the stew on the sequences
and then you'll do some blast queries
against various public databases to
characterize what sorgen organisms are
present or what proteins are present to
each one of these steps you have this
residual data that comes out you have
measurements and metadata from the
samples and you have metadata from the
sequencing as well as the sequences
themselves as well as our intermediate
results and then you have the search
results and the science you want to do
is not about running this workflow right
so workflow systems are fantastic
in fact they have they don't use a
workflow system but they could and they
would get all the benefits but they do
have a pipeline that they built but
they're happy with to generate this but
that's not the solution to this problem
right that's just the way you generate
the data is to run the workflow but when
you run this thing a thousand times or a
hundred times you end up with all sorts
of residual data and then you ask your
science questions over that residual
data ok so our key hypothesis here is
that all of this residual data has a
niqab Uhler structure more most of it
and further that these science questions
that people want to ask are expressible
in SQL and so we build a system to test
these two hypotheses so I'm going to
give you a quick demo first and we'll
talk more about the motivation oops
ignore my email and I don't know how to
see an account with a resolution change
actually so you can log in with we're
connected with Shibboleth and so you can
log in with a particular UW tidy if your
University of Washington you can also
log in with your google ID this is
available on the web you can try it out
you might break it because it's sort of
new but it should work and that took two
clicks last time so we'll see if it does
again so i'm going to log in here
and we're sort of responsive to two
users so if people want other kinds of
ways to login we might provide that the
basic idea here is that you can upload
your data as is without sort of any kind
of pre massaging into a particular
schema or pre-cleaning or or anything we
don't care about your types it can all
just be text we don't we don't care
about any of it and at this point it
looks a little bit like other systems
out there like socrata rich is used by
seattle data gov or Google Fusion Tables
or something else but the key idea that
we're trying to explore is that what if
we didn't feel the need to hide the SQL
from people right what if we allowed
people to sort of exercise the st the
full expressiveness of SQL and so you
see things like all right let's let me
give you a tough one different example
please
a little bit pokey with the internet
connection
okay so all these all these examples
were either uploaded by scientists some
of these are uploaded data some of these
are actual our queries that they rode
which are derived data sets and most of
these are written by the users a few of
these were written by us as examples to
try to explain to them or try to show
them how to write certain kinds of
idioms and the key finding here is that
by just doing this but they're just
providing them a core set of examples
they're able to bootstrap themselves and
start writing SQL themselves even with
no training there's people that aren't
even programmers that are writing SQL
statement so they're happy they're happy
to do this and let me just give you a
quick example the kind of things you can
do this is one of my favorite examples
because it sort of exercises the
expressiveness of SQL so this was a
literal English question that was given
to us you know where they said you know
I don't know how to express this can you
help me I want to find all the tiger fam
IDs which are representing that are
missing from at least one of these three
samples these three datasets right so
how do you express this in in SQL well
there's a couple of ways to do it but
it's actually pretty elegant right Union
together all three samples and then
subtract out their intersection and what
you're left with is all doing all the
individual proteins that are not present
at least one of them I'm not trying to
go into too much detail you I just want
to point out that the set oriented
language that SQL provides is a very
natural fit for some of these questions
that they're already asking so we didn't
sort of manufacture examples that fit
SQL they're providing them to us and
we're and they seemed to work pretty
well okay and so this is you know nine
lines of nine lines of code for
something that's I claim would be more
complex if you did it in a sort of say a
scripting language okay so for each one
of these things you can edit the query
and the resolution is going to give me
in a little bit of trouble here so I'll
probably skip that but you can edit it
and you can derive new data sets and you
can do all the things you might want to
do with queries and so the idea here is
sort of like imagine my grid with
workflows you can sort of do everything
you can do with the workflow you can do
with a query right so everything you do
with a YouTube video you can do with the
query right you can comment on it you
can share it you can read it and so on
all right that's the basic idea so let
me go back to the problem a little bit
here so
we mean by ad hoc research data is
things like this it might be
spreadsheets it might be a ski files it
might be faster formats and we don't
really want to care about how what
format the data is in and so we do a
combination of some writing of parsers
that can understand these various
formats and we also have a few advanced
tricks that I don't have time to get
into that can automatically infer the
structure of files that's based on other
people's research kathleen fisher from
eighteen t in particular okay so one of
the things you people want to do with
this with these data sets well what we
see in practice is that say these are 22
blast hit result tables right so the
first column is the query sequence or
rel ripper and identifier for our query
sequence and the rest if you're familiar
with blast represent various results
from from the similarity scoring the
third column there is the COG hit so
colleges clusters of orthologous groups
it's a public database and this
represents the taxonomic category that
this hit corresponds to and so we see
people doing is taking two sets of these
samples and sorting say in excel on cog
hit and then manually copying and
pasting matching identifiers from one
spreadsheet to another and lining them
up right so what is that operation for
you to litter familiar with databases
it's a joint right so they're manually
implementing joins via copy and paste
and this and three years ago or five
years ago this wasn't that big a deal
right because there was only sort of
working with a few spreadsheets at a
time but it doesn't scare you can't hire
the number of graduate students it
requires to sort of run all your joins
this way and so this is trivial to
express an SQL so this is the key idea
that we want to just find a platform
that can deliver this kind of
expressiveness to scientists okay and
just sometimes it's not always that
simple you have a you might have to go
out on the web and look for sort of
crosswalks between different identifiers
and so on and so forth but essentially
it's just joined you might have to do
nine of them instead of one of them but
it's all just joined ok so there's other
examples you find cases where you have
to use some of the fancy functions thats
a sequel server provides where you can
test if something as a date you have
group by queries and so on but it's all
pretty expressible and this was do we
weren't exactly expecting this right we
didn't we didn't necessarily assume that
everything could be expressed in
SQL but it turns out to be the case
we're having trouble finding examples
they can't be expressed fairly simply
all right I told that I already talked
about that so let me digress a little
bit about relational databases so why
are they why are they even here why are
they so successful well pre relational
if your data organization on disk
changed all your queries broke right
your applications broke and everything
had to be rewritten okay and so Cod's
observation you're worked at IBM and you
win around all the odd games customers
that user database products and figured
out that essentially everybody's doing
about six different things with tables
and if you get those six different
things right you can separate the
physical representation from the logical
query and all sorts of great things in
su so the key idea is that the programs
that manipulate all this tabular data
exhibit an algebraic structure that
allow you to sort of query logically and
let the system translate that into a
physical implementation ok so we called
this term data independence and there's
two types there's physical data
independence which is no longer
manipulating files but actually talking
about relational tables but there's also
logical data independence and this is a
feature in every single relational
database out there but is wildly
underused especially in science which is
the ability to create views right you
can write a query and save it and the
original structure of the data does not
have to be the structure you're actually
query so just obvious everybody ok clear
and heresy I sometimes it's not all
right so there's an algebra of tables I
talked about that algebraic optimization
does everybody know what I mean when I
say algebraic optimization everybody ok
good i'm going to skip that then so
you'd be surprised so the the summer
here is that that what what's provided
by relational database or at least by
the by the language but the logical
model or racial database is a lot of
nice things right there's an intuitive
data model everything's just tables you
can already express a lot of data
cleaning filtering joins aggregation and
so on there's this notion of logical
data independence you have a decorative
query language an algebraic optimization
it scales well you know SQL is the most
successful parallel language ever right
anybody anybody not by that play agreed
ok and there's there's proven results so
what's the point of all this well
databases despite all these great
benefits that we all
sort of agree are there they're under
used in longtail why right so the
conventional wisdom is well the reason
is that scientists won't write SQL we
don't believe this and you can look at
you could you don't believe us you can
look at the results from the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey and life under your
feet and several things that we're also
doing instead we implicate the upfront
cost of install of delivering these
things and it's not just installation
configuration although that's part of it
it's also just this owners task of
schema designer you have to sit down
with them and have meetings about and
draw ER diagrams and they don't care
about any of that crap right they just
want to get started with their data okay
so we asked what kind of platform can
deliver the benefits without all this
other overhead and that's what I the
demo that I showed you it's basically in
the cloud we run it on sequel as your
I'll explain what this is in a second
it's a windows as your app we have a
nice restful interface we have several
different client applications that one I
showed you a sort of the flagship
application that's currently hosted on
ec2 we actually have to back ends right
now one in sequel is your and one on as
a sequel server database running on ec2
this pipe this dis pipeline from here
through to hear is colossally stupid can
you see why
so data that gets uploaded to here is
running on ec2 there's some money to
inbound data transfer then he goes to a
jour which is some inbound data transfer
then he goes back to ec to which is an
interior transfer then it comes back out
and so forth so we're sort of working
that out however I have to say that the
disc combination of things was
remarkably easy to set up and get
running on so even though there's even
though it's probably not a long-term
solution it was fantastic as a
development solution so we're sort of
standardizing on a sequel is your and
we're moving that are moving the web
server onto a hosted platform there you
dub so not to pay anything okay so how
do we use this thing well when we when
we engage with a new lab we do this sort
of mini version of the 20 questions
methodology right we say look give us
your data and give us 20 questions in
English that you want to ask about it
and then we upload it and we translate
some of the some of the initial queries
and then post them in just equal share
and they take those and tweak them and
adjust and drive their own queries and
this simple model has been remarkably
successful again people that don't know
SQL or don't program even are able to
use this kind of stuff okay other use
cases for this thing we're seeing no 11
lab is using it sort of as a poor man
laboratory information management
systems right they track all their
status of all their samples in various
pipelines in spreadsheets but they want
to ask holistic queries and that's
difficult right they want a squirty's
across say seven different spreadsheets
for different people editing all the
time so just upload all these things and
go ahead and ask your question and when
you want to help when you when things
change upload it again it will
automatically replace the old version
right another thing people are doing is
well they know they want a real database
design they want to go through there
they're willing to actually go through
the sort of conventional process of
designing a scheme and so forth but
they're not quite you know ready yet
they don't know quite what the schema
should look like and so this is good as
a pilot project I start throwing your
data into this thing start writing
queries to understand what kind of
structures you have in order to inform
the more heavyweight process later down
the road and that was sort of something
we didn't expect but turns out to be
useful you can use this as a
collaborative query management system
which is a paper from site or 2009 about
the benefits of being able to serve
write queries together as opposed to
independently and so that's a lot of the
sharing
and I mentioned that credit to Alex
delay has this notion of a data
instrument right so they'll put their
data into into a sequel share and use it
sort of as a microscope on the data
temporarily and then ignore it or throw
it out or they can delete it later right
it's just sort of a temporary tool for
helping you to understand what's going
on and that's kind of interesting to it
so doesn't have to be a production
system that hosts an app or anything
else and then the last example here that
I like a lot is an extension for citizen
science right so so most of the work in
citizen science is what I've been
calling sort of stage one which is the
democratization of data collection right
getting people with their service cell
phones to go out and collect data for
you and then you add your data it later
but the only people who are willing to
do are able to do the analysis on that
data are the you know quote real
scientists but Stage two would be
democratized the data analysis as well
and this kind of tool can do that I
think by saying you know anyone's
allowed to ask any question they want
you can derive your own query from
existing queries and so forth okay and
you have the full power of SQL you have
exactly the same interface of the
scientists had you don't have to go you
don't have a dumbed-down interface to it
okay you see just about six months old
but we haven't advertised at all yet how
am i doing on time ok so I'm fine so
since about six months old there's four
different labs around you double campus
and again we haven't advertised yet we
ever really we have a sort of an
official release and so forth coming out
soon there's 50 unique users we have 600
tables uploaded 200 saved queries views
only about a tenth of which we wrote and
there's about 16 gigabytes of data and
that's sort of important this isn't sort
of a large-scale system right this is
for sort of collecting your spreadsheets
together so we don't we haven't talked
too much about the scalability story
here yet although you know a relational
database you could do a lot worse for
for a scalable solution all right so I
want to talk about little bit before i
go about why this is interesting it may
seem like well duh right you know you
put a database put it in the cloud let
people put their data up there and start
the query it well you know that process
I described bootstrapping the scientists
are to help them sort of self-serve in
this system has us in the loop right
we're helping them write the first set
of queries and we're helping them upload
their data and so on so some of these
some of the research projects we have
our
in order to try to get us out of the
loop and just otherwise streamline this
process and I think there's some really
interesting problems too to work on so
one is a very old problem which is
English SQL right so this has been
heavily studied in the database
community the twist that we think we
have on it and Luke zettlemoyer is a CSU
faculty who's an expert in this and this
problem is that since we're not afraid
to show the SQL you can it's okay to
fail it's okay to not get it just right
so with things like Ask Jeeves had a
very difficult task you had to write an
english query and get back the exact
results that the user expected right we
can we can we can get part of the
results we can say you know what it
looks like that phrase in your english
description matches this predicate in a
query but we don't understand what
everything everything else is and that
still might be useful as a way to
bootstrap you early as a way to get
people started writing SQL ok so we're
exploring that there's a project that
actually was underway before I even got
to you Doug which is sequel autocomplete
right so if you take a big query log and
you carve it up into snippets when
people start typing they're at their SQL
you can say ah people just started
typing SQL in the way you just did
typically followed it with these other
snippets as well and so you can help
them kind of auto complete their SQL
based on what other people have already
queried that's kind of interesting a
capability to put into a system like
this to help people bootstrap this one i
like a lot i'm interested in quite a bit
right now which is this initial set of
20 queries you know what if you don't
have a query log already you know you've
just uploaded the data right now and i'm
looking at a blanket blinking cursor
right so what I claim you can do what
we're sort of exploring is look at the
look at the distribution of data in the
date in the tables itself and derive
quote good queries directly from that
you can look at when two tables make
sense to join together you can look at
when a table makes sense to do a group
by query on right and so we're trying to
figure out what this set of heuristics
are and maybe do a little machine
learning on things that have come before
for example stss in order to figure out
a good set of starter queries
automatically from the data they upload
and I think that's that's pretty cool
the other thing you might want is tables
are great you know you can write query
to get back to answers but you really
want visualization or something more
usable and so we're looking at how to
automatically derive dashboards from
this stuff to you upload your data and
you automate
get back some windows exposing various
properties of it and then finally
there's been a lot of work on query
recommendation services but there's been
less so on personalized and so we're
looking a little bit more at since since
we have access to for example UW net IDs
we actually know a little bit about the
person can we sort of steer them towards
astronomy queries if they're an
astronomer and things like that okay so
that's it the again there's a URL you
can actually try to use this thing and I
don't know if there's anybody in the
room here might be among friends but if
you if you're if you're a fan of the no
SQL movement ask me about it and I have
a slide for you alright that's it
questions
too small to read I don't know so it
says I won't read the whole thing out
loud but uh so how do I query the
database it's not a database it's a key
value store okay it's not a database how
do i query it you write a distributed
MapReduce function in her Lane did you
just tell me to go I believe I did Bob
anyway so uh the point is I think
they're I think it's great i think it's
i think there's room for it in the
ecosystem but i think sequels not the
problem things like overuse of mysql was
the problem right oh sorry okay so one
of the things i found in sort of
teaching myself sequel is that the GUI
interface in sequel server you know this
is pretty good mm-hmm and it's a way of
kind of at least getting started with
learning how to design queries and i'm
surprised that that didn't show up in
your so i think that's right so what so
what's the one good question here that's
sort of implicit there is what about the
query editors that automatic that
already come with databases why not just
put one of those online and there's a
there's a few answers to this one the
ones that are already implemented are
pretty simple being able to describe in
English what your query is doing and
save that with the query is nice
actually before you can do that saving
the query right you can say create view
name and so forth we find that to be
pretty heavy weight and that people get
a little bit stuck on that so we've kind
of hidden that from them it is
automatically creating views behind the
scenes but we sort of streamline that
process so that's one little thing the
other thing is you can describe with
some metadata beyond that though all the
collaborative query stuff right when you
can share it and permissions and
favorite it and make comments on it and
so forth is something we're interested
in exploring that make sense so I think
I think the group of the query editor
like that is a great start but there's
these other features we find seem to
have a lot of a payoff if you if you
implement them and we're not sure yet
you know maybe maybe it'll be useless
and all we need is a query editor but
they existed for a long sorry Palmer
thing they existed for a long time and
yet there was an uptake and so we kind
of think there must be something more we
need and we're trying to figure what
that is all right okay great so I'm just
trying to understand the business model
behind this I mean I can't upload 16
terrible
today the right that's right let's what
are the limits right now the limits are
technic are well so one limit is equal
as your has a 50 gigabyte limit that's
one limit there's other you're going to
run another limits even if you can
upload more because it's only a single
site sequel server database but that's
we're really targeting this long tail
with this where the scale is not the
main problem the heterogeneity and then
sort of number of files is the main
problem i would like to see a sort of
fully scalable system out there and
there's definitely some people working
on that sort of thing but that hasn't
been our focus yet hi in terms of your
bootstrapping the scientist your your
four steps or whatever i'm interested in
some comments you might have about the
level of effort that's required to
upload the data on how successful you've
been in you know how many of our cases
you've taken on yeah it's it's it hasn't
been so hard yet but but absolutely
there's a hitch there's a lot of
heterogeneous file formats out there and
if we have we're in the business of
having to write parsers for every single
one of those that would be a problem we
know how to read faster we read a lot of
CSV people export from xpedx so we can
tap into excel if we need to although in
extent aside Excel things aren't always
as rows and columns as you as you can
imagine that's there's an interesting
area of research there that we haven't
quite explored yet and again I mentioned
Kathleen Fisher's work I think that's
very relevant here she can with this pad
system you can it's pretty it's pretty
awesome you can give it examples of a
nasty file format and it will learn the
structure of it over time and
automatically parse it in error check it
and do all kinds of great things we want
to try to tap into some of those ideas
here as well hi Joe futrell from ncsa
I'm a semantic web guy and I don't want
to start a religious war here because I
don't think we have to they meet
different niches I've been interested in
interoperability of scientific data sets
and one of the things that bothers me
about Excel and relational databases is
the lack of any kind of global namespace
control and so you see that as soon as
you try to scale out to a
multidisciplinary team you get problems
it's and we like SQL for a lot of
reasons it's set based it has at least
some notion of some entity which maybe
is associated with a row but I just want
to observe that a
that some of the claims you're making
for for SQL or is exactly the same
claims that you hear Semantic Web people
making for the Semantic Web that it's
right that it's sort of representational
neutral modeling of your information and
you said something like that SQL solves
the problem that when your data changes
your application doesn't break but we've
observed that applications do break when
SQL schemas change and that's because a
database query SQL query is not an
application any more than a sparkle
query as an application server the
application layers on top of these
databases tend to be very closely bound
to the databases and that's because the
database can't do everything the
scientist needs to do so how would you
comment on how you build on top of an
ecosystem like this that can upgrade
your data to say SQL so it's and then
run a real application so it's clear to
me that you're not using vuze in that
application you're talking about there's
a the solution there's logical data
independence and so that when I write an
application against a set of tables and
then I need to reach Ainge my scheme
under the sheets I do two things I
change the scheme under the sheets but I
also make sure I recreate the view to
protect that application from the
changes I just made that's how
relational databases were intended to be
used and that's how no one uses them
right well it exists though technology
works again oh I'm sorry all right
yeah thanks for the talk you mentioned
you're looking at collaborative features
and favoriting and so on but
interestingly we've come allure place
from from another side and this relates
to to joe's kuwait as well on the my
experiment site people share work photos
they have the favoriting and the
collaborative features what we're
observing is that increasingly sharing
sparkle queries so this suppose you're
what you're proposing but reinforces
what you just said as well that's so as
we should be looking at Sparkle no I
think that's fine so sparks or Sparkle
query Sparkle is isomorphic to SQL over
a over a generic simplified schema with
with three columns right the problem is
is that the size of the size of your
query takes that takes the brunt of that
right so if you have a small schema you
have a large query necessarily and so
for the same to do to get the same
result you end up having a sort of three
page sparkle query which is a three line
c equal theory in some in some cases and
I and that's why I sort of prefer SQL
overall I think it's easier to write an
SQL statement then add any equivalent
Sparkle query strip sure okay let's move
on um so our next presenter is dr. Joe
Medina's from University of fur campaign
yes Brazil so I'm wrong with Danny's i'm
here to talk about sin biota 2.0
planning a new generation environmental
information system and i'm actually
representing professor carlos Julie
who's the p.i and this project couldn't
make it here so I'm here his behalf
alright so let's let me put some
background on the talk we are from the
state of são paulo which is a state in
brazil around that region up there and
it it's a very pretty developed state
the best developed state in the country
close to some Western European countries
in terms of development is twenty-two
percent of brazilians population
thirty-three percent of brazilians gdp
brazil's gdp the per capita income's
quite high for you know countries of the
same standard produces forty-two percent
of brazilian exports and it's the
biggest sugarcane producer also in the
country well all this development cubs
at a cost so the vegetation left in this
last 500 years since presume was
discovered it this is what's left in the
state of são paulo more or less so have
to do something about it so in 1999 a
group of researchers from the state they
got together with the research from the
agency main research 20 agency of the
state and created this biota program in
compliance with the convention for for
biological biological diversity and the
goal of the program the program was to
map the biodiversity of the state so
lots of projects people go around and
look for species animals plants all life
forms and collect observations and
material for that recently so this is
more than 10 years now going on there's
a recent science article reviewing the
project you can can take a look as a
byproduct of the project at the
beginning of the the project they
created a new journal called bout new
tropica devoted to publishing original
research about you know the life-forms
in neo tropical regions the papers here
not necessarily linked it to the program
but about new tropical regions built
repco life-forms in general and another
byproduct of this program was that at
some point states
legislators paid attention to what was
being done and not using the information
to provide for instance guidelines for
biodiversity conservation restoration in
the state of são Paulo and also to
prohibit you can prohibit sugarcane
expansion into areas that are most
endangered so this red areas that you
see there and they they selected the
areas based on research done within the
program so it's very interesting of a
case where you see actually signs
influencing government political
decisions all right and then to store
all the information collected over over
the several projects that that comprise
the program at some point they built a
system called sin biota to record all
the observations all the species and and
and all the collections or all the other
observations all the gatherings have to
have GPS coordinates that's a mandatory
in the program so they have the
positions or geographical position can
map that into into the map of the state
now here we have a sample of number of
records and species or some selected
taxonomic groups of importance there is
a map system also with the within the
system so you can you can do several
things like select the region and then
focus on this region make a zoom or you
know several operations are not going
too much into that just to give you an
idea of what the system does right now
however the system served its purpose is
it was very valuable but now the time
has come to to look at the system
it has some shortcomings and you need to
to evolve so here are some of the
shortcomings that researchers have
observed it's hard to expand with new
modules not easily portable if you want
to replicate that to other regions is
also difficult all these three reasons
basically because it's very few
documentation it was written like like
you build a house and then you put a
little room here and I know piecewise
work there is no checking for the
geographic coordinates wherever you
decide to put there except so some of
the observations are in the middle of
the Atlantic and things like the head
have to correct that and spending your
species names also there's some degree
of misspelling there so okay okay and we
need we need to upgrade we need to
improve who need to evolve the system
how do we go about it well the Research
Foundation commissioned TI specialists
from the state recruited them among the
top universities in stayton and ask them
to to come up with a plan and that's
what they they said should be done okay
so first you have to write a reference
document which is a specification for
the new system then make a public call
for implementation groups that's always
a problem who's gonna trim is going to
implement it so make a public hall and
then implement the thing possibly one
module at a time see the current system
was was implemented via a grant to a
group within the within the project but
they didn't have a reference document
they didn't they delivered the system
but documentation was very very scarce
all right okay apart from that there was
a community meeting 2009 last year where
everyone involved in in the project or
in several projects that comprise the
program more than 300 researchers and
students got together for two full days
and discussed what they want in the next
ten years just to put a timeframe
towards the future and this guy's got
together and drafted a document which is
called science planning strategies for
the next decade and this document if
it's part of the science paper as
supplementary materials you want to
download it I know this is being taped
so you can follow the links and stop
through and download it's a 60 page
document but okay so they the researcher
said of something about the system the
various aspects of the program and in
particular of the system also so some
requirements that the community came up
with of course you want to import all
the data from the current system you
have to have a system that it can be
easily replicable and portable to use in
other places other states or in the
whole country or in other countries must
be easily expandable you know want to
include new modules in the future other
than that it would be good to have a
built-in dictionary of species names to
avoid mistakes of misspelling you know
the scientific name stalls in Latin and
stuff so did not ever know it's double
ly or you know so it's good to have a
standard also a mechanism for for
checking the coordinates make sure okay
it's just a bit this thing will be just
a suggestion here someone put okay I saw
I know a lie on in the middle of the
Atlantic so are you sure something like
that of course the researcher is the
final word and import export mechanisms
to communicate with other specialized
tools that do all kinds of analysis on
this biodiversity data this is also
needed and this is some sample of the
tools we were talking about so there's
tools for climate analysis metabolomics
no distribution of species and also DNA
barcoding DNA barcoding was something
that the community very strongly
emphasized that should be considered
what's the barcode well essentially as I
understand it I'm not a biologist but
it's something like a DNA test you do on
the animal and then it's like the the
DNA test we have for identifying humans
who would have four to identify whole
species so you take DNA of something and
match with some kind of table and then
you know which species this animal or
plant belongs to so should be the system
should be somehow aware of the bar
coding and things like that all right
another thing that they ask for is to
expand the cartographic base because you
know state of são paulo the borders are
defined politically but if you're
studying a certain species or a forest
or a live format doesn't care about
political frontier so naturally you're
studying something that goes across the
political front here so you want to
expand the cartographic Basu to the
other regions of Brazil and also to the
sea because many people still study sea
creatures so that's another request and
the final one is for interoperability
with similar systems that these
researchers are using all over the world
we have here the global biodiversity
information facility which is facility
that many many people use other networks
databases and other initiatives in the
state of são paulo funded by the same
research agency like the bioenergy
project a global climate project so i
guess this is yeah this is all we have
for for the community requirements okay
so what happened next is that ok the
this research foundation pop asp
together with microsoft research they
are that size in this third or fourth
year now they are funding projects on
several areas of interest and
particularly actually we r who there is
a brochure outside if you are interested
in all our projects other projects also
funded by but this combination our best
microsoft says it's in the registration
desk when I believe okay so last in last
year's call the biota program got got a
grant from this joint foundations and
the goals of the two-year project and
the goals are to write this reference
document okay take into account all the
community requirements and the
requirements and also implement a
prototype for the new seen biota with
you we are calling here symbiote 2.0 and
so in the rest of the they started all
this was preparation for the talk
actually his talk is going to be in now
we're gonna tell you how a weird
doing right it's almost a year since the
project started okay so about the
reference document we're studying we
want to study all these topics more than
half of them we already have people
looking at the writing reports and stuff
but those are the topics we want to
include in the reference document visits
to user to get feedback whether that's
something we have to do into nothing
will not necessarily be in the document
but study of the the other system
similar systems around the world atlas
of leaving australia encyclopedia of
life gif that i mentioned and others
something about scalability and security
of large databases multimodal data and
search by this i mean the people it's
not in the system right now but in the
future when i put pictures or sounds and
then allow people to search based on
that oh I saw I'm looking for birds that
sing more or less like that then you do
acquire II that'd be wonderful so how to
do that or are we going to require that
in the specification document server of
map systems which map systems you use
which specialized tools we have to
intercommunicate with how to do data
mining on knowledge discovery what what
the system will have to have to to allow
this more easily use of mobile clients
you know you go to the field make your
observations and immediately we can send
the data to the database with your
mobile or PDA or something use of cloud
computing will it be necessary will
people be happy with that you know
having their data in the cloud and so
some people are very restrictive about
that some scientists and social networks
can they help shall we use them what so
this is the topics in the reference
document
we are studying all these topics and
then for the prototype I'm going to say
a few words of what we are doing first
of all there is a current system we
didn't we didn't have a chance to forget
the current system yet for some
technical reasons but we we got part of
it and one of the parts of the scheme of
the database schema and we we notice
that we have access to the database as
user so we can log in and do several
queries and stuff and we notice that the
integrity constraints are somewhat
relaxed I mean you can put things in
shouldn't actually put we don't know
exactly if that's a problem with the
database or or the system but it allows
you to do things that you shouldn't
there is a more redundancy that do that
we think would be appropriate for
instance you put you register the
observation then you want to reference a
paper then when you reference a paper
you have to write all the details of the
paper if you have a second observation
and you're going to ration same paper
you have to enter all the details again
that creates like several copies of the
same paper and and something that
strikes us as funny you see this right
side of the of the schema there's one
table for each taxon rank so its domain
Kingdom and order follows and we taught
them is this the best way to do that so
we thought about it's a long time ok so
we came up with we did with our own
schema which is not exactly a schema
it's it's the what we think is the
modern way of doing something like that
you do a class modeling of the thing and
then use a framework for object
relational mapping so you use object
orientation and then get that map to
relational databases standard tools to
do that and in this in this in this way
of looking at things the text taxonomy
it is just 11 class were table one class
which is a tax on so this if you look at
this as a table so taxon groups are rows
in the text on table the rank is just an
attribute of this thing and you can have
explicit parent-child relationship in
the old scheme we observe that they
didn't have that like if you you can put
a new species or fish say and and say
that this is a son of a general of plant
system would come would not complain so
so we we decide to do something more
strict here it this is more natural for
us i guess the system architecture will
also pay a lot of attention to that
because that's the kind of documentation
that people will need to evolve the
system in the future the prototype so
for the prototype will have a
well-thought and well designed the
system architecture with layers and you
know division classes around each part
here the classes only communicate with
other with some of the other packages
something more controlled and hopefully
people will understand and then for the
map part right now we're using bing maps
and these are some of the maps that you
can do with the system the goal of the
prototype is to imitate what the current
system is doing right now perhaps with a
few additions or some simple additions
but the goal is to imitate what the
system is doing right now and to allow
it to evolve towards what they really
want for symbiote a 2.0 so it's just a
few maps that we we are able to do right
now
you can see that using Bing Maps
automatically the cartographic basis
extended to the whole world if you want
to this is one problem solved another
thing that we are implementing which is
by common nowadays it's auto complete
feature for species names although this
is only part of the problem of
misspelling of species name because the
way people now introduce data into the
system is not by typing but directly to
the web interface but rather they
download a spreadsheet model where they
they go home and they feel all the other
lines with all the rows with later they
collected and then they upload this into
the system so there has to be some
checking in the upload phase also three
more okay I'm right at the at the end
yeah well actually that's that's the end
because now I have links that that go-to
song everything I talked about during
the talk so this is the current virus
virus biota site the journal site the
system and other projects and this three
things in black here at the end are the
sites for the government regulations
using the biota of course it's in
Portugal only a few of you understand
but anyway I decided to put that in
because I know it's going to be taping
and stuff so we can go back and look at
visit their things so that's it thank
you thank you
so this is the first year with the end
of the second year a 10-year plan the
10-year plan yes it's so this is the
10-year plan for it for what they want
to do right and then the project with my
best friend Microsoft is just a two-year
project so this is the first year of
that we have another year to finish the
prototype and to migrate all the data
actually deploy him in the comes in the
end yeah that does conclude this session
thanks again thank you